now today thousands of protesters formed
a 28 mile human chain across Hong Kong
it's the latest in a series of protests
over 11 weeks that have seen escalating
violence between pro-democracy
protesters and police so what's next for
Hong Kong and China will joining me now
is Minister Mark Wei who is from the
Republic of China's embassy here in the
UK thank you very much indeed for being
with us on Sky News these protests this
crisis all began because of the
introduction of an extradition bill
something the protesters are very
concerned about the Hong Kong government
has suspended it can you tell the people
of Hong Kong that it will be withdrawn
as they're demanding first of all lets
me a correct you that you did in a
pronounced the official name of China
craftily I'm from the Embassy of the
People's Republic of China my apologies
whether the Hong Kong government Hong
Kong SAR government has now decided to
suspend the Esso Beijing extradition
bill whether they will withdraw it or
not is up to the Hong Kong SAR
government actually as the chief
executive has made the highest say it's
publicly that the Hong Kong government
proposed the amendment to the fugitive
or in order orden de orden this bail and
they have also decided to suspend it so
the position of the Chinese government
has been support understand
so whatever the Hong Kong SAR comment
decides the Central Park government is
behind that so you have no influence at
all over the Hong Kong government I
think it's up to the Hong Kong SAR
government to do it but you don't have
any influence over that decision no I
can't say I have no implement because
what we practice is one country two
systems' so hong kong people hong kong
people a size high degree of autonomy
hong kong people commandeering
themselves but under the firm work of
one china all thing we have to regard we
have to remember that it is one country
two systems' not two country two
systems'
one country is
equally important like also the two
systems you cannot or we cannot
emphasize words the neglect of the other
side so if it's down to the decision of
Carrie Lam and the Hong Kong government
why are so many people protesting on the
streets why they saying that Beijing is
encroaching on their freedoms I think
there is a huge misunderstanding of the
real situation actually the amendment of
the audience does not violate the one
country two systems or does not emerge
of their rights because of course there
is a large story to tell about how the
amendment came up came about
Kim Kim about to amend the Audis is to
block the loophole of the Hong Kong
legal system actually it contributes to
justice rather than the rather the
otherwise this is what one pro-democracy
leader said Martin Lee QC all they the
Chinese authorities need is a witness
statement saying you committed some
crime 20 years ago that is enough and
then you'll be tried according to
Chinese law in a Chinese Court and who
can trust that system that is what the
people are worried about they're worried
that this extradition bill will mean
people are facing unfair trials in China
first of all will you and your
colleagues stop labeling the people who
joined the protest as Pro mock recei
protesters and miss miss miss using that
the label doesn't represent the actual
truth
what of it because they are using the
fer democracy using the cover of
pro-democracy to engage in violent
illegal activities we could see this
they ransacked the logistical they
attacked the central government's
liaison office Inc in Hong Kong they
defaced the national emblems including
the mesh and also the national flag so
they engaged in violence illegal
activities so your students misuse your
label that's a very small minority 1.7
million people marched on Sunday and I
was there to see them the vast majority
peaceful law-abiding members of the Hong
Kong society that the numbers involved
in violence are tiny I admit that some
of the protests are peaceful protests
because we okay it's a peaceful protest
there will be no problem there will be
no problem because I see protests also
here in London
if it's peaceful there will be no
problem whatsoever but if some of the
Reta course dreams engage in violence
then there isn't it's no longer peaceful
till for a protester actually I read
that Martin Lee himself years ago first
proposed the amendment of the audience
actually because at one time somebody
from Hong Kong committed something a
crime presence in the Chinese mainland
and he didn't want that person to be
trialed try it in the Chinese mainland
saying that the legal system on the
Chinese mainland was not good enough so
he wanted Hong Kong people who committed
crimes okay
in the Chinese mainland to be guided
back to Hong Kong and now he is a
strongly opposed to the audience to the
amendment of the audience so we could
see clearly this flip and a flop and his
what he is doing okay
let's just get back to what you were
saying about the violence involved
because it is a small number of people
who have been violent but they say
they're reacting to police brutality
this is what Amnesty International says
they say Hong Kong police have once
again used tear gas and rubber bullets
in a way that has fallen short of
international standards firing at
retreating protesters in confined areas
where they had little time to leave goes
against the purported objective of
dispersing a crowd violence directed at
police doesn't give officers a green
light to operate outside of
international policing standards they're
saying that they're retaliating against
a brutal police force it is very unfair
to accuse the police of using excessive
violence the police chief has already
made it very clear retreat if the
protesters followed the law followed the
law if the protests are peaceful
protests
if the police were not attacked were not
provoked the place has no reason to use
for use force even if when the use of
force is minimum
I think the Hong Kong police are very
restrained compared to international
internal standard okay so we should find
out who actually started the violence
who permit the police rather accused the
police who is the symbol of rule of law
okay are merely implements you enforcing
the rule of law yeah and of course that
is something that often is very
difficult to to to ascertain during
those protests and I want to just play a
short extract of a speech that was given
by the Ambassador talking about how
China might respond to the protests
let's have a listen further into unrest
and controllable for the government of
the Hong Kong Special Administrative
Region the central government would not
sit on its hands and watch
we have enough solutions and in our
power within the limits of basic law to
quell any unrest swiftly he talks about
quelling unrest quickly what does he
mean by that what tools could he use
because we've seen troops massing on the
border with Hong Kong could you ever see
a situation where live ammunition could
be used on the island of Hong Kong by
troops what is happening in Hong Kong
now it is it is very obvious that apart
from some peaceful protests some people
have degenerated into violent criminal
activity activities if the violence if
the disorder continues it will harm the
interests of Hong Kong hub the
livelihood of the Hong Kong people and
also harm the interests of each and
their business actually so the change
we've got the position of the central
government is very clear
if the situation continues to this the
digital degenerate and it becomes
uncontrollable for the Hong Kong SAR
government the central government will
not sit on its hands
actually these reach that we've seen if
you go into Hong Kong if you read the
Hong Kong Basic Law and the garrison law
you will find your answer so the troops
could effectively go into Hong Kong if
if if it's thought that is necessary I
mean the Chinese government position has
been very clear and he found the answer
seeing the Basic Law lads at the Garrety
law ok um well I also find an answer to
that question whether they use live
ammunition well it's is I it's all in
the law you need to read the law
carefully but you've must you must have
it you must have an answer to that you
tell me what the law is I've got it in
front of me here you tell me are Chinese
troops troops ordered by Beijing if they
came to quell unrest I think they use
live think when the situation arises
obviously the Chinese government and the
Hong Kong government will find a proper
solution to the issue that is to deal
with the arrest swiftly quilled arrest
swiftly and ladies we're not allowed
this happen ok and if that means live
ammunition and that's what do you say
that then there's a very hypothetical
question I cannot possibly comment on it
ok I want to talk about Simon Chang he's
a Hong Kong citizen who works for the
British Consulate had been across the
border into Shenzhen for a day's work
was returning home to Hong Kong when he
was detained do you know what the
situation is now regarding him I think
now the situation is it's very clear
that media including yourself the sky
Sky News has wider reportage what has
happened to this person first of all he
is a Chinese citizen so he's a Chinese
citizen and he violated he broke the
public security law on the Chinese
mainland so now he is dealt with
according to the law so anyway
anywhere everywhere is equal in the eyes
of the law the bin talk that he was
arrested for prostitution is that is
that correct that report that's that's
that's that that's the that's a report
you see using that you read the same
report as I as I read I mean the reason
I'm asking is that if he was on a
high-speed train going from Shenzhen to
Hong Kong how could he have been
visiting a brothel unless there's one on
the train this is essentially what we
see a public security issue I don't have
all the specifics but the information we
have is he violated public security law
and was dealt with according to the law
according to the law okay the foreign
office I don't if you've seen this
statement apologies if you haven't it's
come out fairly recently from the
Foreign Office they are saying that
they're changing their travel advice for
people traveling to Hong Kong this is
what they say in light of ongoing
protests and demonstrations in Hong Kong
there are reports of greater scrutiny
from mainland authorities of border
crossings between the mainland and Hong
Kong you should be aware that the
thresholds for detention and prosecution
in China differ from those in Hong Kong
what do you make of that
I think we do things certainly sometimes
we do things differently you drive on
the left we dry on the right but I guess
the Chinese authorities will of course
act in adult in accordance with the
Chinese laws and they have
responsibility for safety and the public
and the public security and the travel
advisory from the Foreign Office the UK
Foreign Office clearly showed that the
situation in Hong Kong is worrying if
the violence if this order goes on it
will affect Hong Kong economy affected
the livelihood of the Hong Kong people
yeah and their daily lives will be
severely affected so the majority of the
Hong Kong people the public mainstream
public opinion of the Hong Kong people
is that Norma C must be restored order
should be restored so let's hope that
violence will be come to an end as soon
as possible but it's not good look is it
when the British Foreign Office is
advising people to be very careful on
the border because they may get stopped
they may have their phones investigated
it doesn't look good on the
international stage does it they're not
warning people not to go to Hong Kong
because of the protests they're warning
them not to go to Hong Kong because of
how things are dealt with on the border
look I think as as as soon as as
according to what I have already read
about 30-something countries have issued
to travel advisories to Hong Kong which
means that the violence in Hong Kong is
affecting the safety of travelers and
tourists actually I read tourists or
travelers from the Chinese mainland were
molested two were severely you know
detained and attacked they some some
days some days ago as a food inspection
as a borders I strongly believe that
because China is a country and rule of
law and the authorities will act
accordingly in the Codex with with the
laws okay
how do you think this is all going to
end it's been got ongoing now for some
time what's gonna happen next I don't
have the principal crystal ball I read
that some protesters have planned to
obstruct the Hong Kong Airport the
International Airport again but the
courts have issued an injunction order
to prevent to forbid anybody from
obstructing the highway obstructing the
Hong Kong Airport actually I read in the
extinction rubella in the UK that some
people were convicted because for
obstructing the highway obstructing the
police and I understand at their time
the Aviation Minister or your
governments your political leaders want
that obstructing the Hong Kong Airport
my to carry maximum life sentence the
police in Hong Kong had said the same
thing that obstructing the airport it's
a serious crime series offence there's a
stalemate there isn't there the
protesters I spoke to over the weekend
said there is no way they're going to
back down they're going to carry on
there
fight the Hong Kong government who said
that it's not going to back down so far
Carrie Lam certainly hasn't said that
she's going to scrap this bill
altogether you've made it very clear
that Beijing is standing firm something
has got to give
we are standing firm behind the Hong
Kong SAR government we are standing firm
behind the Hong Kong police enforcing
the rule of law so we are standing firm
behind the Hong Kong people - so that
their demands for a peaceful life will
will be met at the chief executive but
has already Alford has already said that
she will start new platforms of dialogue
and she and the government want a
dialogue so so we think dialogue and
compromise and consensus should be the
only way out violence certainly it's not
the way of solving the problems which
every society has different problems but
the violence breaking the law is not
correct path to solve these problems and
very briefly and just finally do you
have any sympathy at all with the
peaceful protesters no peaceful I can't
say no I mean I mean peaceful protest is
never a problem in Hong Kong the problem
you can see is it you could you could
even see this because we thought one
country two systems and on Chinese
mainland Chinese people also are
guaranteed to the right to protest the
right of assembly but in the meantime we
stress a lot of stability we think China
has benefited hugely from stability and
the people cherish this stability that's
why when what happens in Hong Kong when
the riots happen in Hong Kong the people
on the Chinese mainland are very
concerned they were worried so with our
stability you can achieve nothing
okay stability is of high importance so
all of us Chinese mainland and Hong Kong
maybe don't send it to the UK and also
dialogue the wait is the way is the way
to solve it okay a mock way thank you
very much Andy thank you we appreciate
you coming here thank you miss me